et je leading l'offre nous a rejoint en
plateau bonjour je lis vous revenait
tout juste de moscou pour france 24
vous avez couvert notamment ces
mobilisations tous les jours à moscou et
dans d'autres villes rien qu'hier 5000
personnes arrêtées dans 69 villes de
russie selon les ong au v des infos
comment les moscovites et les russes
plus globalement après et cette guerre
comment ils vivent la situation écoutez
on a eu l'impression en fait quand on
était sur place que les gens ne
réalisait pas tout de suite ce qui est
en train de se passer on a eu
l'impression d'une population très
divisée d'une part les personnes plus
âgées ce qui regarde les chaînes
d'information russe un qui est bien
reprennent exactement la propagande du
kremlin en parlant d'agression de la
part des ukrainiens en parlant des
ukrainiens comme des fascistes des
nationalistes qui s'entretuent entre eux
et tuent des civils donc on a eu cette
population là avec lesquels on a pu
parler qui nous disait que et bien la
russie ne faisait que se défendre et que
peut-être que cette guerre aurait dû
avoir lieu bien plus tôt et puis d'autre
part il ya les jeunes qui eux ont accès
à une information plus vaste notamment
bien au mix média occidentaux ou aux
médias indépendants russes pour ce qu'il
en reste encore aujourd'hui eh bien eux
étaient totalement désespéré par cette
situation il avait conscience du poids
des sanctions à venir avec bien les
banques qui commençait à être devenir
très faible avec les grandes marques
occidentales qui commençaient à quitter
le pays et surtout une immense
solidarité vis-à-vis des ukrainiens une
jeune femme me disait poutine est en
train de tuer deux peuples le peuple
ukrainien d'abord sous ces bombes mais
aussi et bien les russes avec cette
jeunesse qui me disait n'avoir aucun
avenir et avoir envie de quitter le pays
on a pu d'ailleurs voir des scènes à
l'aéroport de personnes qui quittaient
le pays notamment bien sûr des
journalistes ou des membres
d'organisations non gouvernementales
mais aussi tout simplement des jeunes
gens qui ont soit perdu leur travail ou
simplement qui ne voit plus d'avenir en
russie des journalistes qu'il quitte le
pays puisque la russie depuis ce
week-end vie sous une chape de plomb un
possible d'informer librement depuis la
russie hausse et c'est très très
compliqué même pour nous un média
occidental puisque la douma la chambre
basse du parlement russe a publié une
loi vendredi dernier en indiquant que
toute personne qui refuserait une fausse
information alors une fausse information
selon la douma c'est tout simplement de
parler mot guerre et bien toute personne
qui diffuseraient des informations de ce
type pourrait être condamné à 15 ans de
prison et cela vise bien sûr les
journalistes aux russes mais également
les journalistes occidentaux ou alors
n'importe quelle personne qui
publieraient sur son réseau social
twitter ou autres des fausses
informations selon encore une fois
l'argumentaire du kremlin donc ça
devient très compliqué on a pu voir le
temps qu'on était sur place et bien
plusieurs médias tout simplement fermé
on pense à la radio historique echo de
moscou 1 qui avait été fondée en 1990 et
dont le slogan était une radio libre
pour les hommes libres et bien elle a
cessé de diffuser on pense au site mais
12 ha on pense aussi à d'autres journaux
indépendants ou alors il ya tout
simplement des journalistes qui ont
décidé de quitter le pays par crainte je
vous le disais le fameux site novaïa
gazeta qui a obtenu qui a été lauréat du
prix nobel de la paix a décidé de se
conformer à ses diktats exigé par la loi
russe pour pouvoir continuer tout
simplement eh bien à travailler mais ça
ne vient pas de la guerre quoi il ne
parle plus de la guerre ils ont des
publier tous les contenus qui faisait
référence à la guerre pour éviter et
bien d'être condamnés et on le voit dans
les manifestations dont vous parlais
tout à l'heure julien beaucoup de
personnes se font arrêter en 5000
personnes hier trois mille à moscou on
s'est rendu à ces manifestations et on a
vu des arrestations systématiques de
toute personne et pourtant il n'y avait
pas de slogans les gens étaient juste
debout statique il se faisait pourtant
arrêté et ça continue merci beaucoup
julie d'une golf pour ce retour de
terrain